great okay so let we've talked about
being at the top and we've talked about
being in the low power positions if we
could just put ourselves in the middle
now middle management and now you are
really trying to build organizational
effectiveness and you have some meeting
of a mind with your boss they feel the
same way you do about loyalty and about
saying what you creating an environment
in which people will say what they think
and feel at all times but your peers are
not happy about this and often in a
large organization there's the middle
manager who's the director of you know
billing and there's the director of
manufacturing and there's the director
of marketing and they all have
potentially competing and difficult sort
of interwoven responsibilities to each
other but no reporting to each other
is there something that you and
recognize a tional effectiveness among a
group like that what do you do in that
middle management place just some easy
problems for - yeah yeah no I think this
is this is as difficult as the hierarchy
problem and I would generalize to say
that those middle people you're talking
about are probably representatives of
the departments that you put them in
yeah that's what their job is is to is
to essentially represent their
departments and discussions about the
tasks whether it's building a car or
taking care of patients and another
barrier to this - saying what you're
thinking and feeling is that the
historical and current relationships
between these different groups so you
gave one which is they may be
competitive with each other and not just
interpersonally competitive they may be
competitive in terms of budgets they may
be competitive in terms of other kinds
of resources they may be competitive in
terms of pathways to greater
responsibility so there may be
competitive with each other they may
have long histories of because of their
specialization of the different groups
mistrusting the other groups perspective
on the shared tasks so that you get a
lot of strategic and quote-unquote
hidden agenda behavior between the two
groups which is exactly antithetical to
what I'm
describing as organizational
effectiveness and as a digression this
is what many people who come to an
organizational psychologist will say
they're saying the threat to our
organizational effectiveness is these
siloed natures exactly yes and they're
not able to communicate with each other
now my interpretation of that is that
what people are saying is people are not
actually talking to each other they're
not saying what they think and feel
positive negative about their shared
tasks which is delivering health care or
making a car because they're so
committed to the groups to which they
belong that they tailor their what they
say in order to advantage one group or
another well we're telling people all
the time to be strategic we're building
strategic leadership we're saying this
is a high-level idea of how to do this
so if you take that to the different
silos it's no wonder that someone might
say well I'm gonna get more in the
department we need and that's important
to the whole task if I just share this
piece of information but not this other
piece right yeah so that's a huge threat
to organizational effectiveness and it's
you know
rampant almost every person in charge of
any organization large or small will
complain about the fact that that things
aren't going well which usually means
decisions aren't being made as well as
they could because different groups
lateral groups are not leveling with
each other communicating involving each
other when they should et cetera is a
huge problem and the answer that I would
give to this is not a quick and dirty
one which is why nobody asks which is to
say you don't solve this problem with a
slogan or with a meeting you solve this
problem with lots of attention both to
the historical and the current
relationship between these groups that
may be natural set up by the
organization it's not pathological we
tend to pathologize these difficult
relationships between groups when we
have created them in order to serve the
organization
so we spend 20 years training a
physician so that they're really good at
being a physician and that means they
have trouble understanding the
contribution of other groups who have
been trained for 10 or 15 years and what
they do but if we didn't train them to
be really good at what they couldn't
accomplish the shared organizational
task but once we do they're speaking
different languages they're looking at
each other's credentials differently
they're they've been trained in their
roles and not in anybody else's roles so
the intervention is quite long-term and
it has to do with a understanding the
history of the groups and be regularly
checking in on what the tensions are
that have been created by the structure
of the way we created deliver healthcare
or make cars there is no way to have
organizational organizations I don't
believe without having sub units that
are bounded departments what we we do
that well what we don't do well is
invest in their relationships with each
other which are going to become strained
and difficult because they were raised
in different professional environments
well it's been tremendous to talk with
you David as always and I think from
this we're really learning about how to
make organizations more effective not an
easy task but something really valuable
to do particularly in healthcare thanks
for your time yep
you